you mentioned ratings uh while you were
gone Brian stelter
got fired the media guy on CNN yes are
you kidding Jeff tuben wait got fired
when they brought him back now he
brought him back
you know they brought him back after he
they brought him yeah after he took out
his tube all right all right nobody's
perfect New Yorker by the way fired
tubing on the spot
and uh CNN suspended him brought him
back but he came back before you left
wait wait wait put tubing aside stelter
is out stelter's out gone
god wow and they did it yeah they did it
uh they did it there's a new CEO who
says he wants wants CNN to get back to
being fair fair and balanced as if they
ever were right uh and late for that and
he's apparently cleaning house he had a
little meeting
the new CNN I think his name is I'm
shocked I mean he had a meeting and said
nobody is secure we want to get back to
not being perceived as a left-wing
Network I'm paraphrasing yeah and then
within days of that meeting Brian
stelter was gone and they gave him a
week or so to say goodbye yeah which was
a mistake because he teed off on the new
owners they are just the discovery right
and the CEO and and teed off on on that
guy uh and then Jeff tuben also got
released wait stelter first off what's
interesting to me about that is like he
sort of became the worst of the worst
you know he's supposed to critique the
media right and you know you're probably
are you friends with Howard Kurtz at all
or you must have done your show did a
show when I ran for girls because he had
the original reliable sources before
stelter and I remember watching that
when I was a kid I was always interested
in media and politics and that stuff and
it was a good show on Sunday mornings
and then he just stelter just became the
worst of the worst like giving everyone
what you think they want all the time
the internet must have required memes
incredible remember when the hunter
Biden laptop story broke of course
stelter was one of those out front
Washington disinformation uh all the
Hallmark Russian disinformation and uh
went off on how fraudulent the story was
and of course it wasn't fraudulent and
he denied that he did that when the tape
was all over the place no no he is the
embodiment of why a lot of us dislike
CNN but as far as I'm concerned Don
Lemon is every bit as bad if not worse
because he reports to be a news guy at
least Delta never pretended to be a news
guy he was he was a commentator a Critic
and why Don Lamont still has a job is
beyond me remember during Josie smallett
turns out Don Lemon called him off the
Record and told him that the Chicago
Police did not believe his story uh and
gave him a heads up a news guy is not
supposed to do that and later on that
that came out and nothing happened to
Don Lemon so
that well none of that surprises me and
my guess is that Le Mans head is on The
Chopping Block too and probably a few
others we'll see but but since this guy
since the new CEO has been in office but
but we've been running the place by the
way about six weeks now their numbers
have gotten worse really yeah so it's so
irreparably damaged the nuclear meltdown
it's begun already the core meltdown
there's there's nothing they can do the
New York Times there's nothing they can
do you step away from it for a little
bit it's so obvious these things are in
their Death Rows and what's interesting
about a guy like stelter is like stelter
has all the opportunity in the world
right now so you're more surprised that
Stoner being fired than the Mar-A-Lago
raid well the Royal Ivory just feels
like yeah the next Trump Adventure it's
like the adventures of Donald Trump you
know it's like Harry Potter and the blah
blah blah it's just Donald Trump and the
raid on Mar-A-Lago okay here we go
stelter though what's interesting is I'm
guaranteeing you this guy is not getting
another decent job but he's done and he
has nobody that's going to support him
like here we are in the local Studio
because a certain amount of people
support me a certain amount of people
support you there's such a like an
incredible uh fertile ground right now
for people that are interesting to to
get out there and get support another
job no he'll get some crappy throwaway
job but I'm saying no no real people
will support him he'll go back to
Washington Post or he'll go back to msnb
hiha which brings up another thing yes
um I made a joke and I said something
about uh what's the over under on
whether msnb Hee Haw hires Delta first
or Liz Cheney oh my God Liz Cheney lost
her primary oh she did good well that
that's yeah good great oh let me ask you
what was it a bloodbath by how many
points do you think she lost it
so I like Harriet Hageman and I had her
on the show and I was very impressed
with her how many points I mean oh my
God was it was it more than 10.
37.
she lost my 37 points that is the
biggest loss of any incumbent uh running
for reelection uh in a primary this
century
that is in the largest one I've ever
heard of 37 points but but I thought she
was the moral face of the Republicans
a concession speech in which he said
she's going to spend the rest of her
energy making sure that Donald Trump
never approaches the White House again I
guess except as a tourist maybe wait
wait so I'm guessing she said that so
I'm guessing now MSNBC and CNN
everyone's saying that she'll be she's
going to run for president probably like
that's got to be the next sister oh she
she was sort of too good for that she
certainly implied it and then she was
interviewed and and she said to me to
the effect of they don't want to see me
on the debate stage with Donald Trump
well as far as I know in order for you
to get on the debate stage you have to
agree to support the eventual nominee
and the whole point about her running is
to make sure that Donald Trump does not
become the nominee so I'm not quite sure
how she's going to navigate that but
there is speculation she may run for
president yes good God